okay well people who are joining this
live stream is going to
quick meeting I certainly hope talking
about um
a variety of things for version 12 let's
see okay general approach description of
uncertain numbers where are we using
that description
yes so the best thing is to review the
page of our own tariff page and my point
there is that there are different ways
of approaching the description of what
our own means and I'm trying to be there
explicitly ambiguous so that we don't
constraint ourselves - I wouldn't call
it mu then I would call it X and DX I
started like that but then in a round
replace we have the replacements of
variables by around so then it's natural
to say X goes - well why don't you say
x0 goes - why don't you say X I mean
something like I see x1 goes so III
that's not a reason to not do it here
well why don't you
say you know X 1 tilde D X 1 or
something something like that here or
the left-hand side could be I mean you
talked about yes so there is a
description in terms of statistics but
the main definition box the warden is
explicitly ambiguous for which put this
up here
yes and certain numbers rather than
going and talk about you know random
Varya it's saying how I agree I wouldn't
say with value that I mean I would say
um what about first why I strongly think
it should be X and DX and I strongly
think it should be minus and plus for
L&R do you mean the set their subscripts
yes ok ok so I'm proposing then let this
become if I can I don't know what this
is doing here
[Music]
ok
well I think we want to use the word
around here represents a number whose
value is around X with uncertainty DX
how does that strike you good I'm still
thinking about the DX the X is fine the
DX perhaps you could be or Delta Delta
then that would be that is a single net
that would be better for to avoid
confusion of products and things in that
oh no worry about the product part of it
I kind of like DX because it allows us
to say DX 1 DX 2 and otherwise we got
you know otherwise we'll have Delta is
it Delta 1 Delta 2 you know those kinds
of things let's try this okay so that
the case we have to okay so um
represents represents
number around X with asymmetric
uncertainty with um maybe we can say
here to make it right
even clearer something like that
represents do you think that's useful
well seems a bit circular in the sense
then our representation of that is
around yeah fair enough
okay fair enough you're right
but we do need to say um is that really
right though this claim here it's not
really quite right but that's what why
not well because
transformations on normal distributions
it's only an approximation to that
yes but the approximation is in the
transformation itself once we have a
round we are assuming the Gaussian
distribution then when we do our an
around replace then we do the
approximation no no but I mean when you
say around something look if I say sine
of around you know PI over 2 comma
whoops PI over 2 comma point 4 for
example that's a case that yes that
right right but that's a linear
approximation so yes but the problem is
not in there around but in the side is
doing the same computation that we I
know that but I think what we should say
in around look represents a value number
with value around and with value around
X and uncertainty DX represents an
approximate number an uncertain number
an approximate number okay so here I
think we need to say if we say here DX I
don't know what I'm gonna get this right
- oops - DX AG very bad idea
help D X underscore + represents a
number with value around
and X and asymmetric uncertainties by
the way does this have numbers with
errors in it yes thank you
good
[Music]
you can you can do this I'm gonna mess
this up for example the DX - so you
think it's clear that the - refers to
the whole DX not just a X I think so I
mean you could get confused but I don't
think you you know I think this is I
think the idea of X plus minus DX is a
reasonable concept here um okay but but
let's let some commutes to represent
measurement results with uncertainties
and other numeric values okay okay let's
say okay let's see around is displayed
in standard form how do we write the
as X plus minus DX where that character
is what if I stay around character so I
see so you can't enter it with the
character there another at the moment in
the future we will have an escape
sequence that creates the template box
for you I think that's a useful first
comment to make here um okay so now I
think we should be saying something
about what this thing oh my gosh we're
out of time this is terrible because we
got to discuss around replace here um I
think we should say around is combined
um yeah that this is
important as well that's very important
statement okay um
when around around numbers are combined
using blah blah blah right and what
about one wasn't promote thus ketosis
that the third argument and the
correlation functions and all that kind
of stuff
oh that's in vector around no it's it's
here but I was planning not to expose
this for a moment because because very
few people use it and the computations
get quite slow so I'm hoping to be able
to improve the speed of all of this I
think it's still useful to show people
that it's possible it helps them
understand what this is okay so let's
say around can be used in numerical
computations is it only numerical well I
want to say something about how how
around is combined automatically
combined in a numerical operation and so
on I see well it's basically calling
around replace to do that and then the
description of how that works is in a
round replace I think you have the page
open okay so there is where there is the
fundamental formula which of course it's
very generalized to the case of
multivariate and Excel but that's the
fundamental step now what are you
proposing in terms of a rename for
around replace yes so the idea is that
now that we have separated vector around
from from around and vector around
represents basically multi normal
distribution then sometimes a round
replace is going to return a vector
around from something that was not a
vector around originally so I have the
impression that if we follow the
precedent of transform distribution and
call this around transform
it's going to feel nicer excuse me but
this is some it has very much the the
look of a replace yes it does but if we
think of the arrows as the wiggling of
distributed it's also a same thing it
does feel like a replace but for example
if you start with a list of objects a
vector in the first argument and you get
a vector around back that feel well okay
so you're saying if I say round replace
and then I say X x squared X cubed right
right and then I say X arrow around to
plus or minus one yes sir right now this
this returns that because it's reading
but I want it to return a vector wrong
because there are correlations among
those numbers so transform distribution
does that just from distribution it
takes a list of random variates and
returns a multi distribution I think we
should follow that as well so okay but
if I would get here if I would say
vector around and how does it what is
the argument to back to around its and
then either the list of sickness if they
are uncorrelated or the covariance
matrix if they are correlated and then a
matrix there for example or yes the
Sigma's that's a vector
why doesn't it type that in a reasonable
why because there is no standard type
set for this why not why not have two
four eight plus minus 1 for 2 1 for 12
because well we could that for there we
could do that for the vector but if we
have a covariance matrix we cannot say
like Star Plus - I'm a tree yeah right
okay so now how do I resolve this
in these type of thing has to go through
through around replace when there are
correlations however how do I get rid of
the correlations how do I say forget the
correlations I haven't prepared any way
for right now perhaps you know you could
say our round of this guy and get the
list of arounds that might make sense
yeah a round of vector around yeah yeah
I mean there's no way that around
replaces can give the right answer
without using some kind of correlated
vector around type mechanism somehow the
fact that now we have separated around
for vector around exposes a lot more the
flexibility of vector one or the
capabilities of doctora why did we do I
mean okay fair enough
um okay very
practical point i I'm clearly we're not
going to be able to Oh Matt what
happened here this meeting got extended
my schedule got all moved around here
well that's good we've got another half
hour in this meeting yes good um okay
all right so the vector case I'm
currently extending it so the scalar
case is is certain okay okay so let's
let's start represents an approximate
number with value around X and it's open
EDX I think that's okay um by the way do
we have a guide page about this stuff or
not yet not yet that was the last point
in the agenda I think because we have
only four functions perhaps the best
thing to do is to put it in one of their
scientific well yeah but we should have
a page specifically about uncertainty
okay look you know what I I want to I
want to make such a page okay oh gosh
why is that dollar M version not working
there
okay so numbers with uncertainty or
something and 17 measurements my worry
is not to confuse people into thinking
that we are going to have here or about
precision such precision etc okay I
think it's
okay and that's going to be alright so
now okay so what we're gonna put in here
this will be um so I mean the basic
point is the often language certainly
pumps as up as obtained for example from
measurements yes how did you guys say
numbers and quantities
okay so here okay well so that's a
number right so the quantity the air out
the quantity is around the around so to
speak it's gonna be inside or outside
yes
you
you
something like that um okay so now we
want to talk about vector around
presumably two containers vector of
correlated numbers with uncertainty
right yes okay so now we also want to
show um quantity and probably quantity
array as well right
yes quantity I reckon half internally
around objects okay eventually we should
happen around array okay so maybe we
should just want to say um well let's
see we want to say quantities with units
maybe maybe that wants to be um um okay
let's just mock up what what else we
have to talk about him we have to talk
about around replace and know mean
around right there the mean around is
important um and then we also need to
start talking about list plot etc etc
etc right and that has various options
um
plot lists of uncertain lists of numbers
with uncertainty odd part lists with
uncertainty indicate
by era bars etc what are the options for
list plot that determined that I think
they are called error bars in every bar
function lunatic
okay so yeah ever of our function and
everyone's type okay oh yes somebody is
asking on our live stream I gotta show
this cuz it's cool okay so let's say
table around n random real - for example
okay
da da
wasn't that cool so which other
functions support this anxious that
supports a robust one our list plot so
we've got also um okay so hold on we've
got um what was the what are those
things called sorry era yes the options
were error bar and this is gonna have to
be knitted into visualization as well
but keep going or about what sorry it's
interval markers and interval markers
style sorry I got an older version
interval
Marcus it's time okay well we need to
okay we'll need to look at that and that
okay so here vector of correlated
numbers will uncertainty all right so
now we want to say
[Music]
go from a number with a distribution to
an around thing so if I say a round of
normal distribution what do I get
do I get what I think I will get
you
you
you
oh that's ensured that that's a bugging
around by the way
right you mean the carrot yeah the
carrot now what happens if I put in here
something other than a normal
distribution let's have a log normal
distribution it's it's going to call ya
mean and standard deviation okay that's
cool
all right okay fine um so let's say um
let's say generating numbers with
uncertainty um and here we want to say
mean around and then we want to say
normal distribution but now if I say
normal distribution of an around what do
I get
no that is not going to work because why
I think it should work you know because
the first argument of normal
distribution is the mean so we would be
describing the mean with a this with an
uncertainty are you sure we shouldn't
hack this to make it work I mean how do
you get out the distribution that
corresponds the normal distribution if
you are claiming that the normal
distribution if you want we can add one
of these properties so because around is
going to be a flexible object for
example we may want to get back a number
with a precision that corresponds to its
error yes quite this so for those type
of things and preparing properties so we
can have an around blah blah blah and
then a property called distribution or
normal distribution okay all right fine
so but let's talk about this then so
okay
generate a number find the mean and
uncertainty of a list of numbers
including the uncertain well find the
mean
let's see how should we say this find um
what is it saying in the actual
documentation mean around I see get the
mean and uncertainty a list of numbers
together without Sun certainty it's a
little weird there there is an important
point here which which is there in an
excluded cell you mean around which is
that when you have a distribution of
numbers this is not going to this
returns there the mean and there's
uncertainty of the mean yes certainty of
the original distribution that generated
the numbers I understand I understand so
I assume that you can do mean around all
the round numbers and that will do the
right thing
yes it's going to take the uncertainties
yeah okay weights okay all right that's
good okay so um here we'll want to say
[Music]
represents an approximate number
um yeah because it's going to compute I
would use returns or gifs okay gives an
approximate number around the mean of
the distribution just with an
uncertainty corresponding to its
standard deviation is that right correct
yes okay now the other case that we've
got here which I don't know how we
usually do this is to indicate the
properties right is it gonna be a table
down below yes I think so yeah okay can
be used in numerical limit can you when
when around is used when around is used
in numerical computations uncertainties
are combined using well when assuming
that they are uncorrelated well using a
linear approximation
assuming no correlations is that even
vaguely correct yes it is correct
because the only way of I think
correlations is either via vector around
or via around replace okay
by default combine using a linear but is
it right to say using a linear
approximation it is using a first-order
approximation yes yes it is some sort of
first order Taylor approximation but I
mean you can say
first on there but how about computed
using a first order Taylor approximation
series approximation why is it Taylor
there's a Taylor series mmm to me they
are sensing okay how about propagated
like you've used here yes that's a
standard okay okay now um okay so the
following properties around dot dot
prop can be used to extract the
following properties reasonable okay so
then first one of those is so trust
remove value so we want to say central
value X in around X comedy acts
uncertainty
what is that if it's asymmetric don't
sit there okay
uncertainty DX in around X DX okay now
what's the next thing we've got here
yes it's simple to compute for example
we have something called approximate
number which will return a number with
precision corresponding to that and
interval school okay so how long are we
really gonna call it approximate number
or yeah I guess so number with value X
and precision if you want you can say
directly accuracy DX or accuracy well
it's a logarithm but it's its accuracy
given by DX actually corresponding to DX
yes okay so next case we have is
interval
basically that right okay um I think we
should also say distribution which gives
the normal distribution so that's
basically xdx right now if it was skew
if it was DX minus DX plus then it's
some dinner I think either would return
some sort of mixture distribution of
some kind I would think I don't know
what is that distribution
yes so layer has something for this it's
a distribution that has 50% of one side
50% in the other side even if they are
not continuous I see I see
oh it's a name distribution or Berber
Berber distribution Rogers distribution
whatever taste with the X minus DX plus
okay okay all right what's this finite
precision numbers intervals and strings
back is a string during there yes so
this is something quite useful because
imagine that you have numbers in a paper
which are which which have zeros on the
right because people want to control
digit sorry significant digits so you
can say a round of a string one point
two zero zero and then go which variate
we need to talk about these things okay
okay so the first thing here
there's a round of I don't know what we
should call it um but kinda think he
acts with the tilde on top or something
um boy I used this that way of getting
these till this once in a blue moon um
gives
so this is so let me know you understand
the case so the first case okay so first
case is an interval right yes but I'm
sure these are important enough to
deserve their own lines well fair enough
then let's say let's combine them all in
one line okay so it's kind of a converse
there from all their representations yes
okay well fine let's let's go ahead and
make it a separate line here oops um all
right round of what do we want to say X
spec or something of spec um give us an
approximate number derived from the
specification spec rise from the well we
say something about what that
specification is um yes so this can be
it can be a number and interval string a
distribution well we already said the
distribution about okay so you want to
keep that one yeah number interval or
string specification spec alright so
then what we have to do
okay so then probably what we want to
say here um in around well here maybe we
goes below this so then the next steps
here we gotta say something about how
the things are displayed after this um
as well uncertainty can be specified as
follows okay so the cases are um we've
got a single number here yes a number we
find it's precision and we will extract
the precision as mean okay a number with
finite precision approximate number with
finite precision an approximate number
whose precision precision whose accuracy
accuracy is used to determine
uncertainty determines accuracy
corresponds to the uncertainty okay
what's the next case here
an interval it's it's the inverse of
what you had what do you have about okay
so this is an x-men hi
definitely not the right thing there
what did I just do um okay well let's
see actually here you know maybe we
should just say approximate number um
and then we can say over here what is
the formula it would be a round of X
comma 10 to minus a kill accuracy of X
okay and this one is a round of x mean
of x-men I can't type this properly and
I'm not going to okay mean of that comma
and then it's x max minus X min / -
isn't it yes oh gosh okay you'll fix
this um okay so now what's next here
thing we have a string well we also have
a distribution let's let's give the
distribution case here
that's not what I meant I meant well to
distribution it's anyone round of mean
of distribution comma standard deviation
of distribution right okay then what
string okay what does that do
it's a string containing a number I
don't know how to represent that perhaps
you're gonna have a number inside the
string that quotes and then it's going
to this will be something like to
expression but then the form there is
not I will define formula for the
uncertainty it's something like one
uncertainty one on the last significant
digit okay uncertainty okay sounds like
a unit uncertainty in the last
significant digit perhaps you can say n
dot xxx or something here yeah to
represent numbers string okay well say n
n dot xxx you know a system for picking
up on incomplete ref pages can trigger
on that xxx
perhaps you can use these like this mass
DDD yah
it's a hack alright okay number string
um okay uh so this is a round of two
expression dot dot dot and intend to
minus the number of these with
uncertainty with with the last digit but
I'll certainly
by the blasted well how was the last
determined by number of significant
digits by a number of significant
decimals no I think it's digits not
decimals right well it depends we
shouldn't count the ends we have to
count the dese let's say I see would it
be too weird to subscript the DS and
then have a handle on the last nuan K or
something that's really weird I think
alright okay so let's let's sum let's
keep going here so on the guide page
alright so um okay so how do we get out
okay first of all okay such dubbers both
in capabilities for computing and
visualizing things just say handling
okay we want to talk about the fact that
it computes and visualize that
visualizes and oh it's okay I think okay
um alright so now do we want to talk
about number form or any of the other
number number display um things how does
reform work with all of this this has
its own type setting so it's not
affected by a number form so that has to
have in the future around form which
will be able to modify this okay let's
see whose value quantity whose value
quantity with units whose value can
include uncertainty that fair yes sir
perhaps you mean whose magnitude okay
okay so now we need to put in somewhere
here yes entity preparation right but
here we want to talk about um
[Music]
distribution specify
distribution to be to approximate with
numbers with uncertainty by numbers with
uncertainty but reasonable hmm well I'm
not sure the sense of approximation here
because it's going to strictly take this
in the mean and standard deviation I
know of that but once it's yes but then
it wouldn't be a normal distribution
would be any distribution
okay well fair enough - well okay use
the distribution to specify numbers with
uncertainty enough that's quite right
because that suggests I mean I'm trying
to give the idea that there's a
connection between these things perhaps
a command dot dot dot okay yeah fair
enough okay all right so then we also
need to give a number with precision
right or interval actually
by the way we should remember um there's
probably a guide page it talks about
intervals that we should include for um
you know where we should include all
these interval markers and so on okay
okay we're out of time here let's go
back to them the around replace which I
really do think is the right name so we
probably just need to say here well
really that's a different situation
because that's that's some symbolic
handling of uncertainty or something is
that right or is that a stupid way to
say it
well it's necessary symbolic because it
can involve all new America iran's it
was call it just uncertainty propagation
a new section together with generating
and then we have there okay so so them
are you propose to say about it replace
replace symbolic variables by uncertain
numbers counting for correlations here
is that of starting with a function of
of their DiSanto budgets so it's
something like replace variables in a
function yeah actually this is
sufficient replace variables by
uncertain numbers accounting for
correlations I think is okay okay okay
all right um okay we're not finished
here
so we're gonna have to go on maybe this
evening would work I I was going to be
away but I'm not going to be um would
that work for you perhaps yeah okay we
might even do a live stream then if we
can arrange that
oh gosh I um well I would imagine
interval markers and so on might be a
question um what other things what
things other than let's plot support all
this stuff very closely related things
like dateless plots list log plot and
then bar chart okay well let's let's put
those in the at least in the list here
okay list log plot does list line plot
support it is a slug plot okay dateless
plot and botcher ice bar chart
interesting and it's support of these
things it will draw error bars
yes I'm but I mean like pie chart will
accept around but it's not going to draw
anything relevant to it I see okay
interval markers so what we want to say
here is option to specify how error bar
intervals should be rendered
should be plotted and what what's the
difference between that and markers
style
the style controls the coloring and
thickness and that sort of thing
coloring thickness etc all very boss
right
yep okay now do you want to say anything
else about other visualization functions
other things don't yet support this
correct correct I mean they will other
things we'll just ignore around that'll
be true right I give a lot of things
well I mean like plot will probably
doesn't know to ignore it yet I need to
double-check that okay okay so we have a
few questions on our live stream I just
want to address those before we wrap
here question was about random reel of
around or that's interesting
random reel I bet we didn't support that
of that did we support that and we
didn't not yet okay
good suggestion mm-hm should we random
variate rights or well buddy both should
work yeah probably
and I think right I'm real what can
technically take a distribution of its
first arguments can it I don't know
let's try it because I think it's you
know we didn't have random variates
originally yes
okay so random real and random I mean
and random variate should support around
good suggestion can I add to approximate
around numbers each with a different
distribution no that is the slippery
slope down which we cannot go the fact
is okay I can say this will work
beautifully I can do any kind of
operation if I do something like this to
the power around you know to come a
point one it'll be magnificent it'll
work perfectly but it's using a
first-order approximation so if I were
to give different distributions here it
will work but only in the first order
approximation
um yeah if you want to actually combine
actually what we should do here is we
should say um we should have a section
under numbers with uncertainty that
talks about exact handling of
distributions and then we should have
just a pointer to things like transform
distribution and so on what are the
things we should point to I would say
standard deviation transform
distribution and covariance mean
standard deviation and covariance and
transform distribution sorry
covariance were saying next covariance
and then transform distribution okay
question
does this work if I take that that round
number and I say mean percent 13 does
that work no should it think it should
well again this is a slippery slope of
forcing around to be propagated
throughout all of this yeah I know which
eventually will happen but the question
is whether that will be a useful thing
to have immediately seems like it would
be useful well mean of a list of arounds
treats them as individual numbers so
having one it's kind of a different
interpretation I see okay
all right we should wrap for right now
and we will try to I'll get the schedule
for later and let me I'll push these
back thanks to folks on the live stream
we will be announcing later live stream
later okay see y'all soon bye